you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video so
here it is the world's largest single
unit hard drive 16 terabytes in this
video we'll take a look at the new
record-breaking drive from Samsung and
then we'll take a look at the fun
factual history of hard drives to put
things into perspective and hopefully
get some brains ticking let's get
straight into it so we all know 16
terabytes is about 16,000 gigabytes but
how much storage is that exactly here's
a nice visualization to give you an idea
please note that this visualization was
made in 2008 and was for 12 terabytes so
I've gone ahead and put the extra 33%
storage on top to make it 16 terabytes
and the updated numbers are about 7
billion single-spaced typewritten pages
3500 DVDs or 12.8 human brains and
that's according to Raymond Kurtz Wells
estimate of the human brains functional
memory ok so 16 terabytes is a lot will
almost 16
technically 15.3 eight of the total 16
terabytes is actual user storage that
aside the most amazing thing is that
this hard drive is not a hard disk drive
but a solid-state drive the kind that
has no moving parts and a much faster
than the traditional spinning disk
drives Samsung first announced the drive
in April of 2015 and creatively titled
it the PM 1633 a it's only 2.5 inches in
width but has a read/write speed of 1.2
gigabytes a second that's so fast that
it needs 16 gigabytes of DRAM and
specially designed firmware to make it
all tick along by comparison the largest
conventional single unit hard drives
made by CJ and Western Digital currently
max out at 8 to 10 terabytes so the
question is how did Samsung do it well
this unprecedented 16 gigabytes of
storage on a single SSD is enabled by
Samsung's new 32 gigabyte NAND flash
Dyer technology the company has managed
to cram 48 layers of these into a single
die
using 3d v-nand technology the simplest
way of describing 3d NAND is to imagine
everything turn on the side so instead
of having just one layer of memory cells
in a single plane you can now have
dozens of layers of cells all standing
up next to each other the V in V nand
refers to the vertical nature of the
cells samsung claims that 3dv nand chip
technology is more reliable than its
predecessors while performing faster and
more efficiently they go on to say that
due to their new technology all 15.3 6
terabytes of usable data can be
rewritten daily without failure in the
press release samsung stated that this
drive is purely for the enterprise
market so that's bad news for PC
enthusiasts though we can expect this
technology to trickle down into consumer
drives in the future there's no pricing
yet available but rest assured it's
going to cost a fair bit but at least
the technology now exists further to
this with time once expensive storage
methods usually come down to an
affordable price
perhaps in two to five years we could
see this kind of storage hit the price
point south of $300 if recent history is
any indication speaking of history for a
wider context and a quick bit of fun
let's see where we've come from in terms
of storage check out this IBM 305 hard
drive from 1956 the 305 was composed of
50 24-inch disks stacked together taking
up 16 square feet of real estate and it
weighed a literal ton and it cost about
$160,000 and stored get this five
megabytes of data as time rolled on
storage capacity managed to increase and
by 1979 250 megabyte hard drives existed
and you're looking at one now as the 80s
rolled around the hard disk drive format
found a great synergy with the personal
computer
here's a 10 megabyte hard drive from
1981 that price you're looking at is
over eight thousand US dollars adjusted
for inflation and finally one more fact
it took 51 years to get to one terabyte
of hard disk storage which was achieved
in 2007 just two years later in 2009 we
had the first two terabyte drive so
while it took 51 years to reach the
first terabyte the second terabyte took
just two years now in 2016 with two
terabyte drives becoming fairly
commonplace and relatively cheap we
clearly live in the future so that's the
past
and the very cutting edge of hard drives
thanks for watching guys I hope you
enjoyed the video if you did feel free
to give it a thumbs up if you're new
here you can subscribe to this channel
definitely do that and if you want to
see some more cool stuff from this
channel hang around for the next 10
seconds and follow the prompts in your
screen cheers guys this has been - gogo
and you've been watching ColdFusion have
a good one and I'll catch you again soon
for the next video